وكان الجوع لم يكفي السودانيين فاشتعلت
الحرب في عاصمه ثالث اكبر دوله افريقيا في
افريقيا مساحه السودان والذي يعرف ايضا
بانه من افقر دول العالم خمسه مليون عدد
سكان السودان ثلثهم يواجهون الجوع فيما
خمسه وستون في المئه منهم تحت خط الفقر
وفق تقرير اممي نشر منذ ثلاث سنوات كما
اعلنت الامم المتحده ومنظمه انقذ الاطفال
الدوليه ان نحو سبعه ملايين لطفل سوداني
محرومون من التعليم وان اثني عشر مليون
اخرين يواجهون خطر الانقطاع عن التعليم
كذلك وسط الازمات زاد التضخم شهريا بنسبه
200% فيما تراجعت قيمه العمله السودانيه
وتضاعف ثمن الخبز عشر مرات منذ ان سيطر
الجيش على السلطه في اكتوبر 2021 وفق
التقرير الاممي ومؤخرا وتحديدا في فبراير
الماضي اعلنت الامم المتحده ان اكثر من
ثلث السكان في السودان سيحتاجون الى
مساعدات انسانيه العام الحالي بسبب زياده
النزوح والجوع معا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات